Tony Dungy former NFL coach now he's a
sports commentator he spoke at the uh
March for Life on Friday let's listen a
little bit of this
well those prayers were answered
damara's recovering now he's home he's
been released from the hospital
[Applause]
but what's the lesson in that
you know an unbelievable thing happened
that night a professional football game
with millions of dollars of ticket money
and advertising money on the line that
game was canceled why
because a life was at stake and people
wanted to see that life saved even
people who aren't necessarily religious
got together and called on God
well that should be encouraging to us
because that's exactly why we're here
today
because every day in this country
innocent lives are at stake the only
difference is they don't belong to a
famous athlete and they're not seen on
national TV
but those lives are still important to
God and in God's eyes
well as you can imagine Tony Dungy being
a mainstream figure as in sports media
now it's been known for a long time that
he's a Conservative Christian
and um
for the most part he's able to get away
with that with being a Conservative
Christian because that's a thing you
have to get away with these days
uh because he's talking about sports but
here he has come out and
actually spoken out forcefully and it's
not the first time he's done it spoken
out forcefully and in public against the
murder of babies and so uh the left
they're just done with them sport the
sports media in particular
this comes from Fox it says Dave zirin
sports editor for the nation said he is
done with Tony Dungy and the way the NFL
NBC coddle his right wing extremism
that's what you just heard In that clip
extremism
ziren says Dungey is some is someone
venerated throughout the NFL world as a
man of character but has spent years as
an anti-gay bigot
Zarin wrote he said publicly and proudly
that he would not want gay football
player Michael Sam on his team he said
over a decade ago that he disagreed with
the lifestyle of Jason Collins the first
out-active male game player in the main
for North American Sports this is a
Dungey staple calling being LGBT a
lifestyle even after people have said to
him repeatedly how hurtful and outdated
such a description is he simply doesn't
care
then ziren goes on and talk about uh how
terrible he is if Dungey wants a show on
The Daily wire more power to him I
totally agree
I mean I can't I'm not in charge of
these things but I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say that we would certainly
love to hire Tony Dungy if he's
interested so uh it wasn't just Dave's
Aaron's a bunch of other people the USA
Today had this article
um taking issue with dungey's what they
call Selective intolerance the article
says what Dungey is not and where he has
far less Authority with which to speak
is a woman
how do you know he's not a woman how do
you know
who must consider an abortion for any
number of reasons but that did not stop
Dungey from invoking Hamlin's name
himself at Friday's anti-abortion March
for Life in Washington DC
um prayer may have prayer may have
helped Hamlin in his recovery that we do
not know but Hamlin was also helped to a
great extent by the medical
professionals and the Bill's employee
and uh and those at the University of
Cincinnati Medical Center Bill's
assistant athletic trainer Denny
Kellington was specifically lauded by
the doctors who worked with Hamlin at
UNC after he was transported there
to Dungy it seems that the use of
Hamlin's name is fair game but only in a
selective sense sadly Dungy selective
intolerance has been in the news far too
often in recent days
intolerance what is he intolerant of in
that in that speech there intolerant of
killing babies I suppose
it's just it's it's a
funny when they try to do this to Tony
Dungy of all people because he's the
most wholesome and beloved guys like the
black Mr Rogers of the NFL he's just
that he's everyone loves him anyone
who's ever played for him loves him no
one has a bad word to say about him
which is very rare in any business or
industry that you could be in that
industry for decades and no one who's
actually worked with you or for you has
anything bad to say about you
um that's really all you need to know
about somebody like if that's the case
then that's a solid person that's a very
good person
so this is all he does it and then on
top of that he just he comes off like
this incredibly inoffensive kind sort of
gentle person
I don't even know what it sounds like
I've seen Tony Dungy on TV for years I
don't know what it would look like or
sound like for him to be angry about
something
and they're trying to take him and turn
him into this rabid frothing at the
mouth extremist which is just pretty
funny that'll do it for this portion of
the show let's move over to the members
block if you're not a member you can
become a member today use code Walsh at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]